hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 20th 2016 what's going on
how are you how are you doing you can't
you know it sounds a little weird I'm in
a hotel in Baltimore Baltimore Baltimore
I can't say that cuz I watch Scarface so
many [ __ ] times I can't watch I can't
say Baltimore without picturing [ __ ]
you know Tony what that [ __ ] AC
coming back on again I mean [ __ ]
times I got a hit off yeah jesus [ __ ]
christ he's a [ __ ] button on here
Lily just says off off here we go
off shut off please shut off thank you
[ __ ] sakes I'm sorry anyway so believe
it or not I'm doing this because I'm
flying back to LA as you're listening to
this and so sad to say I haven't watched
the [ __ ] NBA Finals yet but I do
promise you if Cleveland wins that I
will do something I got to do something
special or something because who's
kidding no the warriors already want it
right if they repeat [ __ ] Sarge held it
too closely if they repeat then it's
going to be like RI can they three-peat
so next year I feel like is their big
thing so that they can go down with all
the teams that have won three in a row
so this year is sort of like you know
you know it's not as exciting
I'm sure warrior fans who I will give
the [ __ ] I'd love to see LeBron do it
you know after everybody gave him [ __ ]
for the way left which they should have
cause like I said he gave everybody
[ __ ] you know Sports blue balls like
maybe I'll go here maybe I'll go there
who wants to buy me a drink yeah he was
been very kunti and then he went to [ __ ]
in Miami Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
happen to her
I could have the TV not on in the
background good lord getting old is the
worst I just saw some woman she had her
[ __ ] head you ever see like when that
the dog gets confused and in [ __ ] her
head like a head was just like that
what is that call what is that from how
do you avoid that as a [ __ ] alternate
neck
exercises you can do on the other side
of your [ __ ] head so that doesn't
happen to you it's so [ __ ] weird what
why can't you just like you know why
can't death just be like the old right
there friend you don't any why's it have
to be just like this slow [ __ ]
dissention into like god knows what the
older I get the most frightening that is
when you're younger just like Jesus that
old [ __ ] what happened to them me I'm
looking at it now go like you know in
the next 20 [ __ ] years you know I
better start eating better Jesus Christ
I'm off the rails with my [ __ ] diet
does anything make you feel fatter than
eating room service in your bed and a
[ __ ] hole just eaten in you in a bed
in general nothing makes you feel fatter
than eaten in a bed you know just
[ __ ] sitting there get crumbs on your
sheets and [ __ ] and you're trying to
scrape it off onto the floor you just
feel like a [ __ ] animal you're like
laying on you I was like literally on my
side I'm in Maryland so I got some sort
of crab cake sandwich of course it
sucked because I got at the hotel
instead of the spot to get it at night
and I'm on my [ __ ] side and I'm
eating the fries I'm literally sitting
there like that [ __ ] lifeguard you
know when he got shit-faced he was
eating the burger and everybody laughed
at Hasselhoff everybody was laughing at
him like it was [ __ ] nuts to me it's
like like is what you never did that you
never just been laying on your foil
floor hammered eating a [ __ ] burger
you should try it sometimes the food is
delicious it takes it to a whole other
level you're so [ __ ] psyched and so
appreciative of the goddamn food you
know do you want to I advocate everybody
doing that this week get [ __ ]
hammered order a burger lay on your
floor just start talking [ __ ] in honor
of Father's Day while your daughter
films you I think that's done think
that's the way to go um people already
text me and you watching a game anywhere
tonight now I'm [ __ ] working actually
somebody tweeted at me going what the
what's what's with your agent why the
hell would your agent book a show you
know when is Game seven of the NBA
Finals it's like hey stupid like it's
not we booked it after Game six this
thing's been on the books for months we
had no [ __ ] idea
yeah I didn't know so anyways I really
want to see I love the Warriors man by
the way you know I have no beef with
those guys but it's just as a sports fan
all the dog in the fight it would just
be great to see LeBron after all the
[ __ ] he got and all those sad sack
Cleveland fans burned his jersey
standing there in their [ __ ] cargo
shorts right burning the Jersey what
people filmed it so [ __ ] stupid that
is so stupid I'm not singling out
Cleveland Cavalier fans but when people
just take sports to that level like when
Lane Kiffin left [ __ ] Tennessee and
that was that one guy going let me tell
you something [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
laying cap and you gonna [ __ ] leave
here you're going to leave here liked
anesthesia we're we ain't no
stepping-stone to USC we're a book and
we're a [ __ ] destination skill is
what I think a [ __ ] lame [ __ ]
camping and I don't know what he had he
had some Lane chipping something or like
a program and he [ __ ] peed on it
a grown man filmed himself peeing on
that program psycho someday you're going
to have kids the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I'll give books by a [ __ ] kid I am
right there they're little dicks out
peeing right with me I don't take it to
that [ __ ] look all that I always
thought was stupid you know this is
something like really like medieval
about like Jesus looks like you're at a
book-burning or something when you
submit burning a jersey you don't
immediately as Jesus going to come down
the street with this cross neck next
thing you start yelling crucify them
it's you know at the end of the [ __ ]
day you know who gives a [ __ ] if you had
the [ __ ] options Cleveland fans all
right abstaining miserable downtown
Cleveland with all those miserable
[ __ ] fans going to Miami Beach with
some of the hottest [ __ ] ass that has
ever been [ __ ]
grace the earth you know beautiful
[ __ ] weather right you buy a
hurricane-proof house I don't what the
[ __ ] that looks like but God knows if
anybody had the money it'd be a [ __ ]
professional athlete you know of course
you would go down there you want a
couple two
what he went three down there all right
fulla fun yet six six finals in a row
and you come back to Cleveland all right
you [ __ ] Snowden [ __ ] here we go
and I'm going to say I'm going to go big
air on this one right now I say if
LeBron if LeBron [ __ ] leads the
Cleveland Cavaliers through the
championship tonight tonight tonight
Game seven seven seven seven yeah
[Music]
in my mind he passes Kobe Bryant I'm
just pausing right now Oh what the [ __ ]
everybody's going to say all that [ __ ] I
just feel like the level of leadership
that he would have to show in order to
do that you know what I mean compared to
the teams that Kobe played on where he
had all this [ __ ] help you know what
I mean because I feel like LeBrons
already done the Kobe championship where
you piled on with Shaq and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] he went down there with
Dwyane Wade and all those guys but to go
to the middle of [ __ ] nowhere as far
as sports goes and lead a [ __ ]
sad-sack [ __ ] City set SEC City Auto
out of the [ __ ] they're cursed
lack of championships is a way bigger
accomplishment than anything any of
Kobe's five that he had you know my big
beef with him is he if Phil Jackson
wasn't the coach and he didn't have
major free agent signings there they
immediately became a 500 team with Kobe
scoring 40 points a night you know just
being like well I got my stats you guys
suck and then he just would walk off the
court I don't know I I would in my
sports mine my unathletic comedic sports
mine I put that with like just watching
like the Pistons walking off the court
when the [ __ ] Bulls finally beaten
those out I was just something [ __ ]
wrong about this walking off the [ __ ]
court we [ __ ] share did she ever walk
off the court she walk off a battleship
ever when she didn't think the sound was
right I have no [ __ ] idea anyway
plowing ahead here
I had an amazing [ __ ] time I did
Newark New Jersey performance at Shannon
whatever the hell they call they had
some great shows and then last night I
played this some [ __ ] place in no I
don't know the names on this run
hang on second typing in the password
one [ __ ] word letter at a time I
played this place last night and it was
the same venue where Mike Tyson knocked
out [ __ ] Michael Spinks now granted
you know the way they sat it when he had
done tie sold the same amount of tickets
believe me they can feed it in all these
different ways so they sat at multiple
common show but when he [ __ ] did it
it was like right now a turtle Gotti
fought they're all these amazing boxing
matches had been there and if you went
in them and I literally felt like I was
in Citizen Kane I got to get you guys
her name of this [ __ ] place one of
the more amazing places I've ever gotten
to walk into had this old [ __ ] this
old organ there and [ __ ] it just doesn't
be on my website enough for [ __ ] sakes
bill oh just look bill bud [ __ ] built
panic City let's see let's see let's see
something-something ballin coming in
French you know you [ __ ] Kyle [ __ ]
it just disappears sounds illegal you're
kicked in the balls it [ __ ] lives
forever on the Internet
[ __ ] one goddamn day later I can't
find it whatever plant ik I'll tell you
ever want to make a zillion dollars in
Atlantic City open up a tattoo removal
[ __ ] a tattoo removal store whatever you
called service Jesus Christ I have those
are some of the worst [ __ ] tattoos
I've ever seen in my life
what the [ __ ] is the name of the venue
you can't this is what I do when I can't
figure it out just start landing City
Boardwalk Hall and actually you know my
back has been way better but just riding
in a car I don't know what it is it just
[ __ ] with my leg I get the nerve starts
acting up again but I'm like 85% of
way back I'm really psyched so I didn't
want to deal with driving that two-hour
thing down the Turnpike so I actually
for once blew a little bit of cash and I
took a helicopter ride down from the
[ __ ] West Side of Manhattan down to
Atlantic City was a ship I flew in an
a-star I got to sit up right next to the
pilot I didn't get one of the seats in
the back which was cool I bought a
ticket and piled on this thing
some other people going down there and
so [ __ ] [ __ ] man he came out like I
was always terrified of being like that
man I don't know if I would want to fly
I still would I would never fly around
Manhattan without an instructor because
it's just so much [ __ ] traffic but he
just go out over the Hudson and just
like you're driving down the street you
just get on the right side I couldn't
look over and see his gauges to see what
altitude we were flying at we went right
down the Hudson River and by the Freedom
Tower and all that stuff and then we got
to the other side the other side we got
the south side and this is you know the
Statue of Liberty's right there Ellis
Island and then we went right over the
Verrazano Bridge and there's no way to
[ __ ] go over that thing and not they
could [ __ ] Saturday Night Fever
you know and that [ __ ] guy Bobby
whatever his [ __ ] name is tries to do
the headstand look at me I'm like you
guys right look at me too like Bobby
don't [ __ ] do it Bobby Emmett is
polyester suit just go all the way down
to the [ __ ] bottom and [ __ ]
[ __ ] I believe I'm in that [ __ ]
scene scared to [ __ ] on me when I was a
kid but now you know just him she's
[ __ ] half row and his [ __ ] big
collar you know it's almost like if he
went in headfirst he would have been
fine or actually maybe it would absorb
too much water and he hit the bottom I
have no idea but anyways we went over
that then we went over Red Bank New
Jersey made a ride went right down the
coast went by Asbury Park saw the
[ __ ] Jersey Shore and actually made
me think like I can't believe I never
went to either one of those places but
down to Atlantic City then we had a
great time down there and tonight I'm
Baltimore so that's basically it but uh
[ __ ] underrated underrated being in
Manhattan blowin a little bit of cash
piling onto a [ __ ] helicopter with a
few other [ __ ] passengers getting the
last seat and [ __ ] flying by that
amazing skyline man it was the [ __ ]
it was the [ __ ] and I finally got to
riding an a-star and it was way less
intimidating than I thought it was going
to be I thought when I looked at the
cockpit all the gauges and everything
brand they were analog I don't like that
digital [ __ ] the [ __ ] hate that stuff
I don't trust it I don't like it I'm not
a technology guy I like when everything
looks like a [ __ ] weird clock then I
feel like I can read it I don't I don't
like all that type of [ __ ] so anyway
coming that's nice to hear I would do
the advertising I just don't know if
it's coming yet see if we got anything
nothing so anyway as always as I've been
trying to mention here so I can support
my fellow comics if you like this
podcast of stuff like this and maybe
you're sick of it and you'd like to
listen to another one we have I feel the
best collection of a podcast on of any
other podcast network at the all things
comedy Network we got Bert Kreischer we
got a who else we got we got a Felipe
Esparza as what's up fool podcast we got
Aaron Foley's [ __ ] sports without
balls we got Dean Dell Rhea's let let
there be talk Doug Stanhope
this is murderous [ __ ] row here bunch
of other [ __ ] people on here and it's
all just high-quality stuff Eddie
Pepitone Tom papa
come on man where else you're going to
get podcast like this
Tom cigar in your mom's house we got all
kinds of stuff there so uh let me click
on a few of these here so I can give
some shoutouts
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank it's a great
website and we just got some investors
on it which is great so we're going to
start having some more original content
which is somewhere I'm trying to drive
some traffic there and be a good [ __ ]
team player okay so after I do my show
here tonight beautiful [ __ ] Baltimore
Baltimore
I'm flying this in my [ __ ] I'm flying
out to LA I go right to the writers room
and after that I'm doing a doing a
benefit that's really important to me
great friend of mine Bobby Slayton
unfortunately his wife passed away a few
months ago and we're doing a benefit in
memory of her
at the Saban theater in Beverly Hills
and the [ __ ] lineup is ridiculous
Arsenio Hall is hosting and there's a
few other up-and-coming comics you might
have heard of like I don't know Ray
Romano Dana Carvey Jon Lovitz Brian
Regan Bob Saget and I'll be [ __ ]
pulling up the rear there low man on the
totem pole and that show would
definitely be me I'm a huge fan all of
those guys so I can't believe I'm going
to get to work with them unfortunately
too it's not the greatest reason why
we're doing it but we love Bobby and
it's a great benefit there are a few
tickets left it's going to be a crazy
show and I have a feeling all those guys
are going to be [ __ ] with each other
because they know each other for so long
and I want to be dick beyond a fanboy
that night and then then after that I go
home and then I go right on a [ __ ]
play and I have to go back to New York
because going to work with some actors
to do some voiceovers we're up to
Episode eight everybody no recording
episode seven
huh dog days of summer we're coming
around we're coming around so [ __ ]
psyched we're up to Episode seven we're
going to do the table read for episode
April record the table the [ __ ]
episode next week hey you know I just
realized you don't be cool is if one of
you guys out there wanted to come to a
table read I got to figure out how to do
a some sort of contest or something
maybe bring you in for episode ten
whenever we record that I don't know why
the [ __ ] I never thought to do that you
know it's funny I don't even bite my
wife to them I'm so busy like poring
over the script making sure you know I
don't [ __ ] up the jokes at the table
read but you know what I'm going to
figure out how to do that and I'm
promising you right now by next Thursday
Thursday's podcast we'll have something
set up for that I think that'd be a
really cool thing if
into the show be not into the show then
you probably like wait bill maybe I just
want to go get a [ __ ] cheese stick or
some [ __ ]
cheese steak sorry anyways let me what
I'm still want to talk about here this
is usually where I do the [ __ ]
advertising against the campus week I'll
Formula One racing how does the European
Grand Prix over there I actually didn't
get a chance to watch that because I
stayed out too late but I did tape it
but spoiler alert spoiler alert Nico
Rosberg [ __ ] Nico Nico Rosberg he won
his fifth [ __ ] race right one two
three four five he's won five of them
he's the points leader he's a he's put
the German team and he's uh just funny
Rosberg you know what I mean it's about
time they [ __ ] made up for it had a
Jewish guy drive them you know I'm no
priest you or anything but he also
drives for Mercedes so I always root for
Germany and Mercedes because I've never
done a background check but I think I'm
mostly German just based on what my
parents have told me but oh my god I saw
the pictures of it too just driving
through this beautiful [ __ ] City
I don't know where the [ __ ] I've been
for so goddamn long when it comes to
Formula One now of course me because I'm
a psycho somebody told me about the
[ __ ] you know basically the formerly
Formula one of a motorcycle racing I
don't know why I'm not watching that I
sit then I flip out where I love all
these [ __ ] crazy contact sports right
you know my like rugby Australian rules
football and this [ __ ] mad mad [ __ ]
that people been showing me lately where
it's sort of rugby sort of soccer and
after somebody scores she can punch him
in the face I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is it's like football soccer rugby
and bullying all at the same [ __ ]
time manages I don't know about that
sports you know the only thing was
missing was just to have a couple of
Bulls run in there and just start
[ __ ] trampling people but anyways let
me shut this [ __ ] TV up this is
really [ __ ] with my brain eeeh
I don't know why if I liked all that
type of [ __ ] why watching somebody ride
a motorcycle two hundred [ __ ] miles
an hour it's absolutely in grilling is
amazing to me is these guys are so good
that when they go down they don't die
somehow you think they I mean not saying
people don't die but you think they
would die every [ __ ] time you know
what I mean the fact that you can wear a
[ __ ] suit that is so goddamn strong
you can go 20 miles an hour and you can
fall off your [ __ ] bike and it just
doesn't like what should happen there is
like after [ __ ] two seconds of
skidding on the asphalt at 200 miles an
hour immediately you should just see the
guy's ass his bare ass should be there
and then you just see it looks like
steak and then it would look like bones
and then that would just be it and the
guy would be dead you would think that
that would happen every time and these
[ __ ] guys just slide in these goddamn
suits they're incredible not saying
people don't die but um I think I think
this is sort of my next thing man
because like you what's funny this time
of year when hockey ends in basketball
in everybody is a football fan you know
pixee the hockey or hoop for the most
part all right very few go hockey and
then wait and go baseball I only know a
couple guys like that so people go
hockey a [ __ ] hoop and people watch
hockey don't watch who people watch hoop
don't [ __ ] watch hockey they have
nothing in common with each other and
the only thing that they have in common
with each other other than their love of
football is the sheer [ __ ] panic of
the day after the game 7 or your final
or your finals when that's over you're
like holy [ __ ] what what am I going to
do now for the next two and a half
[ __ ] months is they wait for the NFL
regular season to start and I'm not
[ __ ] on baseball because I love
baseball
I just get that the [ __ ] dog days of
summer I can't stand like you know who
the [ __ ] wants to go to the ballpark
it's like [ __ ] a hundred degrees out
you know who does die hearts I guess I'm
not a die-hard baseball fan but I love
it I love it in October so I needed a
sport and Formula one dude I'm telling
you
like the race today was it was only like
something like 50 something laps you can
really just sit down and they banging
out a couple hours you know you get to
learn about other [ __ ] cities you
know half of them they go to you like
[ __ ] I'd like to go there get all those
people hanging out calling it right now
at some point I'm going to hit a [ __ ]
country when they have a Formula One
race is actually won here it says the
United States says United States Grand
Prix for the life of me I think it's in
Austin Texas which is really
disappointing to me that that's where
they're going to [ __ ] have it you
know I mean why not [ __ ] is it in Austin
Texas they should add that thing in like
Chicago Chicago should have a Formula
One [ __ ] race that's a cool ass
[ __ ] City you know [ __ ] zipping
over the rivers at one point only one
car could make a they'd probably kill
each other I don't know what the track
looks like in Austin but uh all I know
is Austin is a great city once you're in
it trying to get to it with that [ __ ]
traffic is an absolute goddamn nightmare
so anyways I guess this is a place here
where I would actually pause right and I
would do some sort of advertising I'm
just going to say this so I can edit it
in later we're going to pause here right
now do a little bit of that advertising
where the [ __ ] is my reads come on give
me the reads
give me the reads ah you can't alright
but you know what it doesn't matter you
guys because this is not going to be in
real time for yourself oh my god this
podcast suck as bad as it sounds in my
[ __ ] head right now you know it's
going to say about Baltimore every time
I go to the ball to Baltimore V
Baltimore I always think about the wire
and I was going to go I remember the
wire and I was going to go
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo which is for law and
order I can't even remember how the
[ __ ] song one remembers the song in
the end the guy was screaming up as you
can tell I'm kind of losing my [ __ ]
voice with the voice-over [ __ ] and
screaming about my dick here on stage
but you are psyched about is my [ __ ]
actors coming together and I'm getting
ready to do another special I think I'm
going to do it in October and all I got
to do is just get through these last
three [ __ ] episodes okay give 100% on
that [ __ ] and
and that's it then all of a sudden it's
old Billy [ __ ] flank steak remember
when I said I wasn't going to drink you
know I [ __ ] up on Thursday Friday and
Saturday okay but I was great Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and Sunday right so
when I get back I'm going back to not
drink it I got I got to get back office
but I just I don't know what happened
you know I [ __ ] I don't happen you
know what happened I went on the [ __ ]
Road that's what happened I went to New
York and I met up with some [ __ ]
friends and then hey let's go to this
[ __ ] bar and then you know it's like
when these wine bars you know so you
don't feel like you're drinking so I
showed up you know another buddy of mine
[ __ ] comic I'm not going to send one
name any names this guy's [ __ ]
hilarious and he comes in and it was
lamp first he called him out he just
goes like because he showed up and I
know you saying but why did you go to a
wine bar because there were ladies there
and that's what they [ __ ] picked
right so like I will [ __ ] go there so
he shows up and I immediately go dude
it's a wine bar I don't because he
wanted a beer and a shot his face
[ __ ] dropped and virzi called out he
goes dude the level of [ __ ]
disappointment on your face and then we
find out that they had beer and they did
have a shot but it was just you know
this foofy place so the dude goes go
can't get some drink he goes yeah can I
just get a Bud Light and the guys like
yeah no we don't we don't have Bud Light
we have we have a palpable whatever the
[ __ ] it is some Italian beer and he goes
guys like what he's like a bobble below
but he just goes is is that a beer the
guy goes yeah and he goes alright I'll
have one of those and I don't know what
happened we started doing tequila shots
and the whole [ __ ] thing went off the
rails and I'm a fat [ __ ] and I don't
like myself right now
there I said it I'm [ __ ] in a hotel
room in Baltimore eating french fries in
bed huh like some [ __ ] I don't know
somebody whose dreams didn't come true
that's the week's french fries in bed or
maybe people who [ __ ] everything
worked out for them and then just so
[ __ ] bored they you know like Marlon
Brando whatever the [ __ ] his issue was
I've won every award that exists
bring me a [ __ ] Elks head you just
sat in bed just none on the [ __ ]
Amber's for like ten years and all of a
sudden you know he's ready to do the
[ __ ] what is it with the fun Gorilla
Monsoon movie I have biopic I have no I
don't know how those things work I don't
pretend to [ __ ] know so anyways we're
going to pause here for a little bit of
advertising the fluorines are back with
a monday morning practice okay and we're
back I'm sorry to forget I'll take me
good [ __ ] three minutes to read those
comes to me five minutes whatever that
means I can get to it I can get to the
questions right now can i I think I
can't don't get too close to the mic
bill ii you [ __ ] ask exhale it all
goes off the [ __ ] rails alright here
we go
alright advice first you know some kind
of [ __ ] Ireland some [ __ ] Ireland
gave me [ __ ] about the ticket prices I
think that's a little bit too much I
think you're funny it's like hey douche
how about the fact I'm flying from the
other side of the [ __ ] world almost
onto your [ __ ] doorstep that's not
enough for you who's going to pay for
all that fuel alright here we go
advice for for a daft Scotsman hey there
your redheaded [ __ ] I cannot [ __ ]
wait to go back to Scotland Ireland and
all these [ __ ] places these miserable
[ __ ] are some of the funniest people
you're ever going to meet alright he
says I'm 26 year old guy from near
Glasgow Scotland for quite a while I was
in a bit of a rut but eventually I
managed to pick myself out of it and
decided to do something that I've always
wanted to do I took a big step and
decided to buy a ticket to a festival in
Chicago that's the [ __ ] I love Chicago
said I booked my flights and I'll be in
the city for a week that's tremendous
so basically my question is as I'll be
traveling alone and we'll be staying
alone how easy is it to just hang around
and strike up conversations with
complete strangers in a different
country have you ever found difficulties
in finding common ground in
conversation with people from different
countries also any full pause I should
avoid when talking to Americans so I can
prevent getting my [ __ ] kicked in all
the best you fat shaming prick all right
a lot of questions there well the only
time I ever travelled is when I am doing
stand-up and then after the show there's
always people that just saw you do a
show so I've already broken the ice but
first things first why don't I tell you
a couple places to go to for my little
[ __ ] places to go thing that I have
in my [ __ ] phone that my wife used to
make fun of she made fun of places to go
and she was laughing and then you know
what we went to one of those [ __ ]
places and then all of a sudden you know
she's just she has total faith in it now
she tells me hit all right here's what I
would go alright if you like a nice
[ __ ] a great [ __ ] bar for music
and that type of thing I go to the
liar's club if you like cigars is a
place big cigar Emporium check that
[ __ ] place out and then as far as
food and all that [ __ ] I would just
tweet about it because I'm not a big fan
of deep dish pizza you know what I mean
I just don't understand it
I don't understand deep this piece of
pizza the way I don't understand why
white coffee and tea have to be so
[ __ ] hot you know what I mean
I would so gets the [ __ ] the teabag
all in the water maybe is that what the
[ __ ] it is I just don't understand but
you have to wait like an hour before you
can drink it without scalding your
[ __ ] mouth and when it comes to
deep-dish pizza it's just it's just too
[ __ ] much you know and you can't just
get a slice of it they bring the [ __ ]
thing over it's it's like hey you want
some lasagna yeah but not a whole
[ __ ] tray you know no but you should
definitely try it you get one that
actually has a really good crust it is
pretty amazing but it's just like I mean
you can literally split one piece with
somebody else it's so [ __ ] big and my
wife said the funniest [ __ ] about it she
called it an abomination
she goes it's the ultimate expression of
American gluttony she goes go to Italy
you won't see anything will anything
over there like it that it's true where
we went to Italy you know they have like
we have all our American versions of
their dishes you know to me but there's
no deep dip deep dish pizza in Italy at
least not in any place we went to in
Rome that's the only place I've been to
but you don't see it that's what you
said and she goes you know why because
it's an abomination so anyways as far as
I found in that that liar's club people
will [ __ ] cool as hell if you're into
the music and [ __ ] it's a good time but
dude you're going to be coming over with
your [ __ ] accent I would go to the
[ __ ] and you know I you know depends
on what you're into I would go to a
place where there's going to be a bunch
of beautiful women that's what I would
do and then you go over there and you
just [ __ ] just just start talking and
I think you'll be in the [ __ ] game
and they'll be would you come over here
with me i guy came over by myself I want
always wanted to come to Chicago and
just literally you know hey he called
like his what do you [ __ ] birds do
whatever the flowers were [ __ ] you guys
talked right what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] do
over here for fun yes just wearing
cooked right whatever the [ __ ] you're
going to say and they're going to love
it they're going to love it even if you
ask them hey for a [ __ ] shag and he
however the [ __ ] you say [ __ ] in your
country it's going to seem so cool to
them and so different and then also
they're going to be more adventurous
because you know you're the story's
leaving with you when you go back when
you fly back to Scotland how can you
avoid getting your head kicked in don't
do what everybody else from other
countries do is you come here and you
criticize the United States and talk
about how dumb we are how fat we are how
awful the foreign policy is how our
football players are puts these because
they wear pads why do you call it
football all of that dumb [ __ ] you don't
I mean it's so [ __ ] obnoxious you
know you know I said not just because
they've kind of
people always come here and they act
like these these worldly travel people
you know and oh I come from here and I
come from there and we can do this and
we can do that and it's just like well
in all of that [ __ ] travel you never
learn to be on your best behavior when
you come to somebody's country and you
don't come in and then sulf it so you
make your whole country look like a
bunch of [ __ ] snobby [ __ ] you never
learned that one I am oh we I'm on my
best [ __ ] behavior when I go to a
different country I'm not saying I'll go
out and get [ __ ] hammered but like I
don't go there and [ __ ] on it you know
some of these places I go to them
[ __ ] talking people I nice place is
nice there was a lot of [ __ ] did you
come here where I was I can I was in
Oslo Norway I said you know I'm gonna be
you guys well thanks a lot you guys but
great I'll definitely be back if
somebody yells out why that you're
struggling what what do mean why why the
[ __ ] wouldn't nice [ __ ] beautiful
I don't know anyway so I would avoid
doing that and then just everything else
was common sense you know somebody's you
know looking like a psycho just [ __ ]
leave him alone but I don't know I I
mean I judge a lot of Scotland on that
movie Trainspotting but I just feel like
it I don't go into any bars where
there's an upper deck to it because I
just feel like there's going to be that
guy up there that's going to finish his
[ __ ] pint and just throw the glass
over his head cut open some woman's face
like I just you know if it's even
remotely like that over there I think
you're going to be fine in Chicago I
would definitely try to go to a Cubs
game no offense to white sox fans but
you know you guys all know that your
[ __ ] stadium stinks you know it
stinks it's the only time I ever saw
Stadium a new stadium built and they
admitted so quickly like wow we really
[ __ ] this up what started like it was
like a botched nose job you know I mean
like your stadium is is the [ __ ]
stadium version of like you know in some
Hollywood chick or somebody they get too
much work done on their face and people
oh my god what happened that's what you
did with that stadium me like what
what's wait till it settles let's see
what happens you know they're so they go
but did you pick the great [ __ ] city
to go to Chicago is the [ __ ] and I
picked a great time of the year
I will tell you the traffic is [ __ ]
horrific so just get ready for that but
once you're in it it's [ __ ]
phenomenal alright where do we go here
alright dear Billy stretchy pants on
your podcast some time back you were
talking about someone getting with
someone else and one of the people
gaining a bunch of weight oh yeah when
you start dating somebody how it's not
fair to the other person for you to then
put on a bunch of [ __ ] weight unless
your woman you having a baby that's
obviously yeah I'm not a [ __ ] animal
here but I'm just saying you know after
you have the kid you know that's what
that's when you know it's after your
wife has a kid two things should happen
this is what you do you get a little
bassinet for the beautiful baby and then
the second thing you do is you get an
elliptical for your wife but so she
doesn't get mad at you what you do is
you get our initials engraved on the
side of it in plastic of course totally
kidding all right I was already a few
weeks into whipping myself back into
shape okay let me start this over again
because I didn't forgot what the [ __ ]
he's talking about on your podcast
sometimes back you sometime back you
were talking about someone getting with
someone else and one of the people
gaining a bunch of weight I was already
a few weeks into whipping myself back
into shape but this really helped me
solidify my will well that's [ __ ]
great man that's great I wish can you
help me because I you know what's
sitting in a [ __ ] writers room is
like I eat there like the way I eat on
the road I mean I just [ __ ] hard to
try to eat healthy just you just bored
you're freaking out you locked in the
[ __ ] room you're like I'm going to
eat some [ __ ] candy for no reason I'm
sitting there every day like it's
Halloween and I'm [ __ ] seven years
old I got to stop alright huh it made me
think that I should really give my lady
the respect of maintaining something
close to the body I had when she got on
this train she loves me she stayed with
me in spite of the lumpy beanbag chair I
had become a mound fifteen pounds down
with a bunch more to go but I am back on
my routine four or five trips to the gym
at 5:30 in the morning dude you [ __ ]
killing it that's great and calorie
counting as well I know
exactly what to do it's just the time
now my question is this how do you deal
with it if your lady wants you to eat
the same stuff she is or wants to go to
a shitty fried food restaurant anyways
thanks man hope season 2 Baptist family
is coming along well it is thank you sir
can't wait to see it and I loved your
last show in Austin hurry back and come
during the football season we had a
monster [ __ ] recruiting class this
year thanks you bastard oh that's great
man you could Longhorn should be good
it's a legendary college program there
all right um all right how do you do it
I would just say I won just set these as
easy just sit down with her and just say
hey listen you know when you got with me
I was however years old and I would I
weighed this much and I don't think it's
fair for me to have put on all this
[ __ ] weight you know and to be
looking like a lumpy beanbag chair like
you said so I'm really trying to get
myself back into shape so I was
wondering if you know you know if you
want to eat something that's a little
unhealthy is there any way we just can
go to a place that has healthy options
for me all right
because I don't want to look bad for you
and I also don't want to die early so
you're [ __ ] you know in your 40s and
50s having to put lipstick on and get
the [ __ ] back out there again and try to
meet somebody works down at Sears you
know and I don't want to do that to you
I'd like to be here for the long haul
dude there's no [ __ ] way she she'll
give you [ __ ] about that that that's a
very easy thing to have happen you know
and then also I think sorry I'm looking
at the timing I also think that she
would be happy to hear that you you
weren't just doing this for some vain
reason yourself that you're actually
also doing it for her I think that that
would be pretty cool now watch
now watch your [ __ ] getting some big
[ __ ] fight you know are you seeing
you saying I eat bad you say I'm fat
yeah she blows your sales manager all
right read this okay all right I'm going
to read this Lex what's up [ __ ]
let's go [ __ ] Bruins can't wait for
next season I just moved to wildly
mediocre Los Angeles
well yeah that's what you're going to
feel like because you just
I can move there but if you stay
open-minded which is really difficult
for East Coast people to do I did that
the first time I came to LA I went to LA
and I tried to do Boston New York [ __ ]
and then when I couldn't I was like this
police [ __ ] sucks
it doesn't it's [ __ ] amazing
beautiful women some of the best food
you ever going to have so much outdoor
activity
just [ __ ] embrace it stop trying to
be the [ __ ] Boston guy you're not on
a reality show alright take it down a
few [ __ ] notches
nobody gives a [ __ ] in Los Angeles that
you don't like it everybody just thinks
well then go back to [ __ ] Boston go
back to Philly whatever the [ __ ] you
from if it's so [ __ ] great why did
you accept a job out here alright sorry
I'm just heading you off at the past
before you come another [ __ ] [ __ ] on
[ __ ] LA he said I work for the UFC
editing fight highlights thanks for
keeping me entertained with your
semi-literate bibble battle [ __ ] day
after day this is like a classic East
Coast guy he really likes me and likes
what I what I do but he just can't get
himself to say it because his dad never
hugged him so I'm not taking any of this
personally anyway my girlfriend is about
to move here to meet me she had to stay
behind when I move because she's a
teacher needed to finish out the school
year we get along great I trust her and
she treats me better than I deserve
however sometimes I can't take how
[ __ ] she can be well start to pull
some threads there she is successful and
very book smart but sometimes lacks
common sense I find myself feeling
embarrassed when she says some stupid
[ __ ] in front of my friends or parents
it's kind of a hard thing to discuss
with her though you know what should
what the [ __ ] should I do also I'm
coming to your show at the Saban theatre
this Monday I'm looking forward to it so
don't blow it well I appreciate you
coming out to that like I said it's you
know for a really good friend of mine
and for a great cause so thank you for
doing that
all right away is our deal do you either
have to accept the fact that she can be
a little ditzy or you have to come to
the realization that you're dating a
[ __ ] dope and you got to get rid of
her it's one of the other
I mean look she doesn't sound like she's
sent that I've dated people like that
that we're a little you know they were
either locked in or just sort of
floating it was really weird and they
could say really like amazing like
spot-on [ __ ] and then two minutes later
could just could say something like oh
my god what the [ __ ] was that but I have
to tell you that's kind of that's kind
of a big deal they'll do you know you
can't think that the person you're
dating is a dope you know you get into
that situation and you start thinking
about getting married you start think
about having kids you're like it's my
kid going to be half a dope or a full-on
dope is a kid going to get all of that
DNA from her who the [ __ ] knows it's
kind of a good thing to discuss with her
you know what are you going to say to it
can you stop saying dumb [ __ ] I mean
there's no way to do that you know
trying to think that's like my wife
telling me to work on my I mean I do
work on my temper but I mean it's kind
of how I'm made up I mean if somebody
did see they [ __ ] did see that were
you like my wife telling me okay can you
be a little less pasty it's like I can
become red for a few days and that's
about the best I can do I don't know
what else you want for me but you know I
think you need to maybe move on I'm not
saying you need to move on yeah you
either accept this about her aren't you
got you got to walk one of the other all
right here's another one Jesus Christ
can't come and I don't mean to the
wedding how's it going Billy
Butterball's if you're reading this on
Monday it's [ __ ] sick June 20th
will is my 21st birthday oh Jesus I
don't know what's going on here great
gift here and you read this well you're
not going to hear it until the [ __ ]
Monday anyways all right I'm kneeling
I'm kneeling I'm emailing today though
is I was with this girl last summer some
good sex no big deal but we didn't have
anything going on during the year when
we were at college well we're back at at
this summer but the thing is I can't
come I mean I'm doing good pretty good
PPM pumps permitted but I just can't
finish now I know you're not a doctor
so not going to ask you why but how
should I go about this I think she's
getting self-conscious but she's a hard
eight and I'm a soft six she's hot it's
not a fault daddy can finish daddy can't
finish when the pressure is on how
should I be playing this I can only
laugh it off for so long I'll try not
jerking off - maybe that'll help any
advice thanks for the read man hopefully
I'll be able to come check you out when
you come back East Coast maybe Baltimore
and Sunday go Sox go [ __ ] yourself yeah
I you know don't rub one out if you're
watching too much porn maybe that's a
problem or maybe you know you don't want
to be in a relationship with her and
that's the weird way your body is
reacting like you're wasting time so
we're not going to [ __ ] I don't know
there's a billion psychological reasons
but yeah yeah just don't rub one out for
a while you know this is nothing two
women a [ __ ] they're very forgiving
people if you I would I wouldn't laugh
it off I would talk to about and just
say listen obviously this is happening
it's bothering me I'm feeling pressure
about it and I'm also feeling like in a
roundabout I just don't want you to be
taking my issue on like there's
something you are doing you're not doing
anything wrong there's something going
on with me and then she'll be like well
maybe you should go talk to somebody
about it because you're [ __ ] Red Sox
fan I'm assuming you're from the Boston
area you don't want to go to therapy and
even if you do go to therapy it's not
going to help because you probably have
enough Irish blood in you and they
always said who is that [ __ ]
psychologist that said the Irish are
like
immune to therapy I don't know if you
like this girl I would definitely talk
to her about it but there's no reason to
put any pressure on yourself you know
what I mean just don't rub one out don't
watch any porn just you know I don't
know
just let it back up that time I don't
[ __ ] almost doctor Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ are here we go here we go
wine it down wine it down alright heroin
I have no family no friends I work and
support myself I have no kid
no relationship I actually enjoy freedom
and being alone to extent I'm in my 20s
I had a lot of sex relationships and
ended up getting herpes / HPV I would
basically rather just not tell people
and not have relationships than to have
than to have to at 35 years old didn't
ask you at 35 years old deal with having
to explain / tell this to women I really
like heroine what the [ __ ] Jesus Christ
buddy what are we doing here this
doesn't sound real I really like heroin
I go to work come home and use heroin on
a daily basis I still pay my bills I
still work but I have traded the
pleasure of sex / having a family /
relationships for that up watching TV
shows / movies while high on heroin
falling asleep then going to work the
next day should I change this is this
real I'll try you know what I'll treat
it Israel should I listen to society
stop using go out there and find women
and tell them about my situation hope
they do not reject me and get clean or
if I am happy is it okay for me to just
accept the women part of my life is over
eat whatever I want
use whatever drug I want and fill the
time I have left on this planet watching
shows movies playing games and resigning
myself to the fact that I will be alone
love the podcast heroin gets a bad rap
it may sound crazy but people can use
opiates and still be responsible I know
many people who do it's like alcohol
both can be physically this is really
fascinating or maybe it's a big lie I
don't know it's Apple it's like alcohol
both can be physically addictive alcohol
can actually kill you which withdrawals
while heroin cannot and the depth you
hear about heroin are from idiots
overdosing if we will what if you get a
bad batch isn't that something you know
it's too [ __ ] strong I don't know I
don't pretend to know all right if we
reported all the deaths from alcohol
involved incidents they are easily well
they do report all of them as far as I
know it's like they're trying to hide
them they are easily 100 times more than
heroin rule
debts but in our society right now
opiates are not acceptable because too
many white middle-class parents are
finding their idiot kids using them
without understanding tolerance / proper
dosing anyways love the podcast I'm not
leaving any contact info so I have no
way to know if you read this just
thought it might be an interesting
subject for your show it is interesting
yeah dude I don't pretend to know
anything about opiates all I do know is
that they I know alcohol can ruin your
life but I don't think it's nearly as
addicting as heroin I have heard that
people can [ __ ] enough but I think I
think if what you're saying is true I
think you're a rare person that can
handle that I have no idea that [ __ ] now
I gotta look some [ __ ] up the last thing
I wanted to do and I got to get going
here I get my [ __ ] show here and a
half-hour all the live reeds are here
the live reeds are here I guess I'll
read them here then let me just see
something let me just look up alright
look up productive while on heroin
heroin in employment independent drug
Martin let's see productivity and heroin
addiction what is this how heroin
addicts in Vietnam
what is this productivity and how in
addiction how living in a cave turned me
into a blogger I failed my new year's
resolution I wish I could do better I
just don't have enough willpower have
you ever set a goal you didn't achieve
ever tried a new year's resolution that
didn't stick what separates the 0.5
percent from the 99 and a half percent
what makes someone some people succeed
in building new sustainable habits but
almost everyone else fails how living in
a cage and where the [ __ ] the heroin
[ __ ] how heroin addicts in Vietnam and
your productivity habits are the same
what everyone knows the horrible effects
of heroin and addiction once someone
starts taking
it's almost impossible to quit and those
who form a recurring habit will likely
never quit so why didn't heroin using
Vietnam vets relapse when they returned
to the USA a study from the Washington
School mobile volver medicine very few
heroin use in Vietnam veteran relapses
what very few heroin using veteran
relapsed relapsed when they returned the
USA and those who did were more likely
to have been illicit drug users before
ever arriving in Vietnam these threats
weren't addicted to the chemicals in
heroin they were addicted to the
experience of powerin in a specific
situational context in the same vein you
think you are in control of what you do
you think that when you fail it's a
failure of your willpower but the fact
is you don't even realize the influence
of the environment has on you did you
know that obesity spreads through a
network of friends happiness also
spreads throughout a social network your
situation determines your choices as
much as or more and your own personal
choices win willpower so how can I use
this to improve my habit oh Jesus Christ
now join a Wally ball league I don't
know what the [ __ ] that was all right
let me let me look up just read these
[ __ ] things here you know what I
might read up on that I probably won't
I'll try to I would never tell people to
[ __ ] yeah it's just heroin you know
that seems a little crazy to me and
people always come in and alcohol it's
like the [ __ ] pot smokers always
doing that [ __ ] well alcohol actually
man there's no medicinal purposes just
[ __ ] it I get it I get it but you
know you guys are also you know you're
pie-in-the-sky [ __ ] thing with weed
like it's like this that you can't get
addicted to weed is another [ __ ] fact
Jesus Christ okay yeah you just really
like it that's all you know all right
you're unique all this is helix helix
you're unique you don't walk like
everyone else talk like everyone else is
sleep like everyone else so why is your
mattress one-size-fits-all because a
truly customized mattress will cost you
five to ten thousand bucks until now go
to hell it's helix Lea calm answer a few
simple questions and they'll run a 3d
bio chem bio something or other model of
your body
to the proprietary algorithms they
develop with the help of the world's
leading era gamma supply of elderly
experts the result the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on telex
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality and for couples
they customize each side of the mattress
your mattress arrived I just pictured
somebody having one like the husband's
they could bang a woman while his wife's
sleeping and she wouldn't know you know
rather than doing the red wine test well
one guy jumps up and down while the red
wine just sits there you know what about
mattresses for those people Hilux
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality and for customer
couples they customize each side of the
mattress your mattress arrives at your
door in about a week and shipping is
100% free that's why everyone from GQ
magazine to Forbes are all talking about
helix sleep you have 100 nights to try
it out if you don't love it they pick it
up for free and give you 100% refund no
questions asked gross what do they do
with that mattress go to helix sleep
calm slash burn and get a $50 $50 off
your order that's helic sleep calm / /
helix sleep calm / / well here we go but
me on DS me on D sleeping on a dirty
mattress but do me undies be undies
that's because you got a flat ass but
when you put me on these around your
flat ass take off your [ __ ] balls and
your taint to get some undies everybody
needs them Muslims Christians and Jews
oh yeah alright me undies whenever
you're wearing a suit or sweats you
spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear but instead of making a
statement like Superman's tight under
tights under his clothes every day your
underwear is probably boring the undies
is here to change that all right every
pair of me undies is made by sustainable
source modal Modell a fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton nothing can
describe the fit and feel of me undies
but once you try them on your balls will
never go back and you'll understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear and if you don't
love your first pair of me undies
they're free no questions asked
well I'm glad you don't take them back
like the [ __ ] mattress store the
undies has dozens of styles and limited
edition Princeton
you make us help you make a statement
with your underwear whether anyone can
see them or not remember Superman
all right shipping it's free in the
United States and Canada and you can
save up to eight bucks prepare that me
me undies with the me undies
subscription plan get the subscription
or a single pair get 20% off your first
order when you go to the undies dot-com
slash bird that's me undies dot-com
slash / right Eunji Starcom / Berg
alright lastly but certainly not least
week is a Dollar Shave Club everybody
dolla [ __ ] shade Club kid guys Dollar
Shave Club really appreciates you
listening to these advertisements on
this show and they wanted to thank you
all right
what are they done here at
dollarshaveclub.com they arranged for
them to one give new members a month of
the executive razor for free just for
buying a tube of dr. Carvey shea butter
aka dr. cobby VV shape but they're super
excited for you to try this alright now
let me remind you why millions of others
have joined prize proud members of the
club dollarshaveclub.com delivers
amazing razors right to your front door
for third of the price of what the
greedy greedy greedy greedy razor
corporations charge that means when you
join Dollar Shave Club you can afford to
shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic
alright get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade and that's
without hurting your wallet alright and
then after you get the executive blade
you use a little dr. kavak easy shave
butter and the blade just gently glides
across your smooth surface
something-or-other whatever shea butter
isn't your average shave cream it's a
unique conditioning formula the high
quality natural ingredients leaders can
feeling unbelievably soft and smooth
it's soft as a horse's muzzle now it's a
great time to join Dollar Shave
qualification had no new members who buy
a tube of dr. Chavez ez shave butter get
a month of the executive razor for free
e take advantage of this special offer
today it's available by going to
dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / alright
that's the podcast for this week I
apologize it's a little bit short but
I'm kind of short on time alright if
you'd like to donate to this podcast a
great way to do it next time you go into
amazon.com just go to Bill bird comm you
click on the podcast page click on the
amazon link and they'll take you right
to Amazon doesn't cost you any more
money they kick me a couple of bucks to
drive in traffic their way once again as
always have a great week you [ __ ]
[ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll talk
to y'all check in on you on Thursday